you know it's a special kind of
disappointment when it comes at the
hands of people or an organization that
you have been vocally supporting
[Music]
before sag
Afra oh so
you may or may not have heard last week
sag after reached an agreement for the
use of uh Ai and AI replicas to be
created for video games and interactive
media with a specific AI company so this
isn't uh a broad overarching one this is
with a specific
organization and voice actors are
pissed like really really ticked off I
caught wind of this pretty quick I
didn't know if I was going to talk about
it though not because I don't think it's
important it is um I was kind of hoping
more people would talk about it this has
not gotten nearly the coverage it should
have so that's the first thing the
second thing is I really didn't want to
have to try and parse
through you know
negotiation documentation or summations
or any of the
kinds of stuff that I had to go through
talking about the sagaa agreement and
the resolution of that strike I was kind
of burnt out on trying to parse that
stuff so I I I just didn't have it in
me well as I said not enough people have
talked about it and it's pretty bad so
we are going to cover it now this is not
going to be like a point foro going
through it the way I did with the um
summation of the sagaa agreement that
resolved that strike um partially
because we don't have the same degree of
details what we have right now at least
that appears to be publicly available is
just a blog post from sag aftera
updating what had happened we don't have
a summation or bullet points or anything
like that so there's less for me to go
over but it is still vague to the point
that I didn't really want to parse it
and my focus is going to be much less on
the specific wording of the agreement
I'll go over some of it and I'll talk
about some of the concerns that have
been raised by people affected by it but
I want to talk much more about how this
appears to have happened or at least the
questions that are raised based on how
this appears to have happened
and why why did this happen so before we
cover the why we should probably uh take
a look at the fact that this is not a
good thing so an agreement was reached
with a company called
replica and that will allow them to make
offers to voice actors to create AI
voice replicas that can then be licensed
and used in future
projects the thing that the SAG after
announcement focuses on is what was
quote unquote earned in this you know
they are required to actually get
consent and permission to do this that
actors do not have to give license in
perpetuity there isn't a lot of details
about what the residual and payout would
be but the thing is
the only version uh of this that where
even if there is good residual payout
forever there probably isn't but let's
assume for a second there is that's
still a
problem
because most voice actors aren't looking
to just kick back and get residuals for
the rest of their lives performers like
to perform most voice actors well most
of any kind of actor but yeah we're
talking about voice actors here most
voice actors don't want to just sit back
and collect a paycheck I mean like we
live in a capitalist Society I'm sure
they do want to collect a paycheck but
most of them want to keep
working because this is an artistic
medium it's something that people tend
to be very passionate about so most of
them don't want to just sign away the
rights to their voice to be used in
future projects while they sit at home
get bored out of their mind because
nobody is actually hiring them to stand
in a booth and work anymore and another
thing about this is an actor does not
even have to sign up to allow their
voice to be used for these AI models to
get completely screwed over cuz all it's
going to take is a couple of
recognizable voices to sign off on this
and do you really think that a AAA video
game studio is going to hire a voice
actor that nobody knows the name of when
they could get a voice replica of a
celebrity for probably comparable price
if not cheaper now there are a lot of
concerns about this one of the major
ones and this did also come up with the
sagra deal that resolved the uh the
strike last year but it it is a lot more
front and center in this one because an
actual Flatout agreement was reached
with an AI company whereas that
agreement between sa saaa and the
studios was with them and that still
required additional stuff to be worked
out with those kinds of companies so
what I'm going to talk about there was
this kind of concern there but it's much
bigger here and that is the concern that
yeah
technically performers have the right to
say no I don't want my AI uh my voice to
be used to create an AI
replica but that can start becoming a
requirement for work if you want to work
this gig you have to let us do that
there is already concern that that could
happen with liveaction actors in film
and TV as well that is less of a
pressing con concern because AI voice
replication is a hell of a lot farther
along uh than actual visual Recreations
of somebody so whereas with the film and
TV actors the concern was a little bit
more about heading off future things uh
at the past this is very much already
viable the ability to create AI replicas
like you may or may not have either seen
uh or heard I guess rather voice filters
on things like Tik Tok that just make
you sound different this artificial
intelligence lets you speak with any and
I mean any celebrity voice in real time
just tremendous real time but the
question is who really is considered to
be a celebrity it's already
frighteningly plausible so whereas with
the uh previous agreement that ended the
main strike that was that was mostly to
head off future issues this was already
an issue and sagaa appears to have just
conceded to it so so yeah this is this
is this is a big problem and this is
immediate but I'm not going to focus on
the ins and outs of the deal itself
because as I said I don't know a lot of
details what I will talk about
though is the fact that this happened
behind closed
doors and appears to have happened with
very little if any approval from the
actual affected members it is the claim
of sagra that
The Proposal was quote approved by
affected members of the Union's
voiceover performer community that is
vague as hell it doesn't say how many
members were consulted or had any kind
of internal vote we don't even know to
what degree their approval was was it
just them looking at going that looks
good did they have veto power who were
they that last one's actually a pretty
big one because one of the things that
has happened is a heck of a lot of voice
actors including some of the most
prominent names in video game voices
have come forward and said not only did
I know nothing about this going on I
don't know anyone who was consulted a
very specific person who said that was
Steve Blum the man is a staple of video
game voice acting and actually video
game voice acting at least for prominent
characters as opposed to background or
uh smaller one-off characters is a much
smaller Community than you'd think you
check the credits for a lot of things
and you will find the same several dozen
people showing up in dang near anything
if it's know AAA High budget video game
development so this is not that huge an
acting pool and he has said flat out I
heard nothing about this and I don't
know anyone who has so who the hell were
the affected members who approved this
we don't
know this is almost the complete
opposite of what happened when the
strike initiated last year because
there everything was very upfront like
here's what's going on in the
negotiation here's the breakdown here's
where we're having problems here's why
we're striking and even after they got
uh a deal it got put to the members to
vote this was not voted on not by the
membership at large it wasn't brought to
them negotiations weren't talked about
this is just something that it was said
hey this is a thing and this seems
completely at odds with how sayra dealt
with the earlier strike and particular
around the issues of AI it is almost a
complete turnaround at least from the
philosophical standpoint of guarding
actors jobs from being taken by a AI
because again it's not just a matter of
money yes the money is also a problem
because again we have bills to pay we
have rent to pay we need to be able to
live I say we I'm not in the union but
you know we collectively the people um
and these actors as well so the money
does matter but just knowing that
they're not going to get replaced and
they're going to get to continue to work
because again this is a passion career
this is a passion industry you may not
be passionate about every single job
that you do but the work in of itself
you are doing it or you got into it
because you want to do this so even if
you make proper residuals on this you
won't get to work as
much why would they outow for that when
they tried so much harder to guard
against it on film and TV
actors well the first thing that I'm not
going to bring up is I'm not going to do
any kind of speculation or at this point
lend any Credence to any idea of
impropriety or bribery or somebody being
paid off or what have you I am not going
to say that it is that such a thing is
impossible but I am going to say at
present there is literally no evidence
of that and I do not want to stoke that
kind of narrative here without any
evidence that having been said as
cautious as I am
about um being overly speculative and in
general being very wary of
conspiratorial
narratives I am going to be a little bit
speculative about this in a way that
unfortunately has to be slightly
conspiratorial because on its face this
makes no sense on its face it does not
make sense that they just threw the the
video game voice actors to the wolves
and didn't call for stes didn't call for
support didn't didn't do anything they
just came forward and said hey we cut
this deal and and uh people approved it
who who did what do how the lack of
transparency the suddenness of this it
is all a complete
180 so
why well as I said I am going to get
slightly speculative about this well
actually let's start with something that
isn't particularly speculative but is
unfortunate which is that TV and film
actors are simply better protected and
more
valued like the fact that voice actors
in general and actor and performers who
do things other than you know the major
TV and film um performance stuff which
was the division that was striking um
you know last year because there are
other divisions of the
Union the fact that they are valued more
highly and also like numerically kind of
make up the bulk of it that that's
something everybody knows but it's rare
to see it so blatantly on display that
they were fought for and the video game
voice actors were not video game voice
actors were on the picket lines they
were supporting these other people and
they had a right to expect the same kind
of support for their own similar issues
and it just well I was going to say it
didn't happen it wasn't even given a
chance to happen because there's a
decent chance other that other actors
would have joined them on the picket
line but they didn't even have the
option that kind of leads me into the
first thing uh out of the two things
that I'm going to float as being
possible reasons because again on its
face this makes no sense so I have to
come up with something and I don't want
to get overly accusatory uh and
conspiratorial about it but okay I'm
going to jump in here I actually had a
whole thing that I went off on that
looking at it in the edit actually
doesn't make sense but in
double-checking some things I have found
what does make sense so sag after is
actually currently in active
negotiations with the biggest video game
companies in the world and back in
September a strike was authorized now an
authorization is not the same as a
strike beginning authorizing it simply
means it is on the table as a tool in
negotiations so far as I can tell those
negotiations have not wrapped up no
strike has been called so they're
continuing to work under the existing
agreement but now I cannot help but
wonder if this is meant to influence
those negotiations if possibly the
leadership of sag came to the conclusion
that they weren't going to get the
concessions about not using AI that they
were hoping to get and instead opted to
try and do separate negotiations with a
company so that they can now say to the
video game companies hey okay if you're
going to do that you have to do it
through these people that we have an
agreement with which in the broadest
sense I could kind of get if you feel
like you can't win on a certain point at
least doing what you can to take control
of it is a tactic that makes sense but
that doesn't remove the issues with how
skey this was done and how it cut out
the voting members but I wouldn't be
shocked if part of the reason for this
is to avoid another strike
possibly for political reasons with Saga
not wanting to appear to be just a
monkey wrench in the machine that
strikes all the dang time those Optics
would not be great for the organization
doesn't make this okay they cut out the
actual affected members that needs to be
underlined and never forgotten but then
there's the other thing as I said there
was some AI that is not massively
dissimilar to this at least in principle
in the SAG after deal from last year in
terms of okay this stuff we're not going
to ban it entirely but it it has to be
consented to there have to be these
agreements it's not in
perpetuity the from glance at the
summation the god it's not summation the
blog post that we got that deal was
probably had more guard rails in place
than than this does um but I can't be
certain of that but that's that's
certainly the feel of it but as I said a
lot of that is
speculative because AI for
recreating um actors visibly I'm not
going to say doesn't exist but it's
difficult it's expensive and it's not
quite there
yet so there's a part of me that
wonders was sag aftera willing to send
the voice actors out into the Wilderness
throw them to the Wolves to see how
badly they get
mauled
because if things move forward and I
don't think this scenario is likely but
let's consider all possibilities here if
things move forward and just the AI
thing just doesn't really go anywhere it
doesn't uh get used that much most
people don't agree to it and they are
still getting work even though they
don't agree to it then the union might
feel um comfortable not being as uh
tough on AI issues on on future contract
negotiations because they'll have
they'll have a point of reference where
it's not purely hypothetical or flip
side if the voice actors start getting
replaced left and right then sag aftera
will know how hard it has to fight
against AI the next time the contract
negotiations for the rest of the Union
comes
up again I don't want to actually accuse
them of handling the voice actors for
video games as a sacrificial lamb but it
would be an explanation it would be a
reason
because
otherwise what the hell and just
the
disrespect cuz like to be clear voice
actors for video games while their
contracts are not all lumped together
with the section of the Union that was
striking last year they're part of the
same Union they pay the same dues they
are supposed to get the same kind of
protection they are supposed to have
their jobs fought for to the same
degree even though they are a separate
section that get has its own contracts
being negotiated at different times and
with different bodies than what happened
last year they're still part of the same
Union they're supposed to get the same
backing and they didn't they just didn't
I can almost guarantee you if this had
been put to a vote especially if it had
been put to a vote only to the affected
voice actors m of the Union it would
have got shut
down I can't find anybody who says this
is a good idea now that's not to say
literally every voice actor is speaking
out against it no that is that would be
an exaggeration but I have not found any
voice actors who have gone on the record
or said anything publicly who had
anything positive or even neutral to say
about this everybody who has spoken has
says this is a terrible deal and they
feel betrayed and I don't blame them
does this mean I'm going to stop
supporting sag after our unions in
general no it doesn't unions are still
important unions are vital but unions
are also not infallible unions can and
will make bad decisions bad
calls and just do they are
capable of it they are not immune from
it but their existence is still vital so
that there is some kind of counter to
the powers
of Corporations and conglomerates
Etc but let this be a
reminder unions aren't perfect we need
them and I will not stop supporting
unions as a whole I'm not even going to
stop supporting sag after in specific
but this specific
deal is absolute and like I say
I won't stop supporting them like that's
all philosophical for me anyway I'm not
a
member but it also means
that I have even less reason to stay
quiet like would it harm my potential
membership into the union for me to say
you messed up and you did something
crappy maybe realistically I was never
going to get an offer so let's just be
honest this was a terrible deal and they
screwed over
people people who they made it very
clear they don't think as well of
as the kind of actors who were striking
last
year so there we
go voice replicas God damn it what do
you think about all this whatever your
thoughts might be drop something down in
the comments let's talk about it try not
to get any more conspiratorial than the
degree to which I was willing to go
don't let it turn into just a spiral of
nonsense in the comments um but if you
want to support what I can do patreon is
a huge help for that but even if you
can't support me that way like share
subscribe links to other things I do in
the descript description but don't worry
too much about it what I really want you
to remember especially if you got the
raw end of this
deal you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
[Music]
adjourned drum roll for my highest
supporting patrons Robin Moore Lula
goddess Ela Oliver B to roac the thing
that goes dink in the anime Ruth go of
the gazarian solitary pictures olrick
Bogden geek filter Linda Walters Toby
Jackson Jen Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks
fori likes the poodle Robin Powell TLO
czy scrapit angry casel Dave Hall quite
bearish Rosalyn Bennett pal baraba jle
and miror G thanks so much
[Music]
w
m